environ sept heures du matin quand au
beau milieu de ce champ de bananes
quartier belle étoile
les employés de l'exploitation retrouve
le corps d'une femme sans vie dans sa
voiture portes ouvertes vitres baissées
les employés ont tout de suite compris
qu'il y avait un problème
jao levée du che mai à 7h du matin
trouve c'est pas normal quotidienne de
tout le monde ça je le conçois donc
c'était dur avant donc que du coup on a
été au plus près aux gardes et si
c'était vraiment ça est dû qu on a vu
qu'elles répondaient pas aux consignes
de vie puisqu'elle avait déjà patiné
cherchez pas sur place le médecin
légiste constate le décès quelques
minutes plus tard des proches arrivent
sur les lieux
et selon les témoignages la femme âgée
de 47 ans était durant le week end
pascal à la pointe marin avec ses amis
sa famille et son père en vacances sur
l'île
le dimanche soir elle laisse ses filles
de 9 et 13 ans sur place avec ses
proches en leur disant qu'elle doit
partir réparer sa voiture n'ayant aucune
nouvelle
un avis de recherche est déposée à la
gendarmerie le lundi après midi
il est rejeté à la pointe foulage la
plaie on se retourne d'apprendre l'après
midi et je suis pas passé du tout la
voir parce que j'habite en face donc
j'aurais pu venir
et puis c'est ce matin qu'on m'a appelé
pour me dire que l'on a retrouvée quand
on fait quand je les ai eus au téléphone
elle m'a dit qu'elle n'était pas bien
quoi sans plus elle n'allait pas bien
sans plus et avant ça elle avait déjà
parlé de quelque chose bien d'un
problème
non non mais je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé
cela faisait un peu plus de quatre ans
que la jeune femme s'était installée
définitivement avec ses filles dans la
commune du vauclin une enquête est
ouverte pour déterminer les causes du
décès